my darkest moment because the team it's
been a year and a half and I came to the
realization like there's no way this
game is gonna work this is not a good
game it's a self else's follow yes it is
and you realize like okay that's all on
me and also it's one of those tricky
things with design is that when your
ideas don't work which is all the time
but when they don't work it's not like
you put in your second best idea you're
like that was my best idea so people
like well that doesn't work so do do the
good one and you're like that that was
the good one that was what I thought was
a good one so you have to go back and
like just okay
I'm starting from scratch in Canada so
that's that was on a big scale but
that's how it is pretty much everyday
InDesign incoming transmission hello
commander and welcome back to GameSpot's
three-part series on XCOM to yesterday
we talked about the history of XCOM but
we stopped short in 2012 when this
series made a remarkable comeback this
story starts with the hiring of Jake
Solomon who decided to apply for
position at Sid Meier's for access games
the studio that made his favorite
videogame 1994's XCOM
who have been chosen to lead this
initiative to oversee our first and last
line of defense
I actually took a job with like a
consulting firm I was gonna be a
business consultant and I even I even
like they came in like a signing bonus
and everything and and then I got an
interview with her exes who I love and
so I went out there and I'd never seen a
game studio before they're just these
really nice people in this big penthouse
office and I interviewed with Sid Meier
you know any showed me this dinosaur
game is working I was like hey what do
you think I should do here I was like oh
my god I can't believe he's happening I
just can't believe that was a job and so
the problem was that I'd spit by signing
MOUs and then I did call a couple nails
like hey is it okay if I know okay no
it's not okay so I need to I need to pay
back okay that's fine yeah I still had
to pay back this huge tiny motor and
that was 15 50 and a half years ago now
and so I've been there for 15 years I've
been there the whole time and I I'll be
there another 59 it's just to me it's I
love it I love the company and so it's
just been perfect Jake was in the door
and was soon programming on some of her
accesses most popular franchises but
through working alongside Sid Meier his
eye for design was deepening and it was
through this mentor-protege relationship
that Jake began to turn from a
programmer into a designer a sifter is
my first game I was a graphics
programmer actually a 2d and that was a
2-d game so that was like one of the
last 2d games I remember the big thing I
did was I added alpha blending to these
animated 2d animations and the artist
would like nice this young kids got the
stuff and I yeah I remember I did
fireworks over the cities and we loved
the King day so and then after that I
actually am working with Sid on all the
SIDS projects so that's how I really got
into design is that then I worked on sin
golf and then pirates and all of sids
projects going forward SIV Reve I worked
with Sid and that was he's also a
programmer but obviously he's mostly
that's how I sort of learned okay it's
great like it's a great skill
combination to be a program but there's
a lot to learn when it comes to design
and you know a lot of our people have
been there a long time and learning a
working proceed for 10 plus years before
I did any design work was my way of sort
of picking up how we do things
Jake was learning how to make games but
the one game he wanted to make was the
same one that inspired him to work at
four axes in the first place XCOM so how
did this plucky young coder get the keys
to one of gaming's most fondly
remembered strategy games you know we're
doing stuff at fractious and they'd say
oh you know what should we do next you
know I'd be like exco then be like yeah
then it come up again the other two
years later wish he were kind of like
axe cop [ __ ] were connected and so they
let me do a um let me do a prototype and
it was terrible
it was awful it was such a bad game
she's a bad prototype and at that point
it was like okay we're not gonna do XCOM
and that was when I went worked on Civ
Rev and I really learned a lot from it
and after that after our relationship
once a friend he was kind of like you
know I think it's I think it's time for
you to try again and then we sort of
started up the whole project that ended
up becoming ended up creating a sequel
to a game like XCOM is a monumental
responsibility how do you make something
which appeals to people's love of the
old games while still making it
approachable for modern gamers XCOM is a
fantastic game but go back and play it
today and you'll be reminded of just how
top heavy and cumbersome it could be
it's incredibly complex there's a lot
going on so I asked Jake when you
originally got the thumbs up to remake
XCOM how did he choose one elements to
bring back and which ones to leave in
the past
hostile classified there are a couple of
cores to that and I won the soldiers you
know the fact that there was perma death
always that is what always stuck with me
is that there was an actual emotional
connection to soldier and this is from
the original the stakes of the game are
real a lot more real than any other game
where if somebody dies you know they
conscious they wake back up or something
and you're like well I'm not I don't
have any skin in the game but I'm ex-con
you know they would die and then you're
like I got they're gone and when you win
you know when you achieve victory it
feels authentic because the losing
condition is serious like you'll lose
your soldiers and so when your soldiers
get stronger it's an authentic sense of
like okay kids something I actually
risked something to win this reward and
then there are the things like
destructible terrain was a big part like
that's very XCOM is to have these sort
of destructive dynamic environments you
know and so for me those were kind of
like the core tenants and then of course
the idea that you've got this strategy
layer you've got the comment layer
research you know building stuff for a
fan of the series the relaunch of XCOM
was incredibly satisfying it captured
the tension and tactical nuance of the
original game but presented it in such a
streamlined fashion that the more
complex aspects of base management never
really felt that intimidating it's the
type of game that could only be made by
a true fan of the series but also
somebody with the enormous pressure to
make their first game sell it had to
appeal to fans of the series and gamers
who hadn't played the original equally
an incredibly challenging task but one
Jake and a teammate for access made look
easy
I can't lie there is a surprise I love
it but yeah I mean yeah I think that we
made a game and as a team we were like
well this is like we like it it's really
fun and then there are people at the
publisher and they're like this is
really fun and you're like yeah trust as
a design I'm the type who's like hate
all my stuff so I'm just like that's
that good but you know then some more
people saying like oh we really like it
and but the question is does it find an
audience you know so the hardest part is
like if you make something that people
like oh this is really fun I like this
that's the hardest part
but then that happens a lot of times and
it's like is there an audience for that
and this game was definitely I think
that was the big question is
is there an audience there's no game
like this you know it's turn-based
strategy you know there's there's no
game like this is there an audience and
then we were very fortunate that yeah
there wasn't on it there's a big
audience for and so it was a bit of a
roller coaster
XCOM went on to critical and commercial
success it received dozens of accolades
including Game of the Year awards from
Giant Bomb and taco and game trailers
and it had commercial success across a
wide range of platforms getting a game
to multiple markets helps it sell more
but it was also key in the success
ex-cons design the big problem we made
with the our first prototype instead it
was a crazy over complicated and I think
that thinking about okay platforms and
things like that
it helped us when we started to say like
what is the what is the core of the
experience like we don't want to lose
anything and we I don't feel like we we
lost anything because of platforms but
we thought we had to think like okay if
you have to have it work in all these
different environments and you have to
sort of think about what's the core the
experience what's important that's how
you design your UI and it was actually
really really courageous a great box to
working that was the story of ex-cons
return but it's not over yet tomorrow we
talk about the difficult follow-up album
the changes Jake wants to make and how
it won't just be another underwater risk
it
see you then commander